i have a a melty kiss as they're called
as they say in all the commercials yeah
um and uh i don't particularly like
these you know
uh it's just uh much here what have you
been watching
yeah it's like mochi with like chocolate
on it yeah well
let's give it a shot for you you're not
a fan of mochi
ah mochi's hair mystery of course
because they're
individually packaged yeah love the
packaging
you say you will it's [ __ ] pretty
like the box makes you want the thing
the thing about melty kiss is melted
kiss is one of those
uh brands in japan that is always
seasonal they always
have a seasonal flavor of melty kiss you
you can tell what time period you are
in when you go to a supermarket or a
kombini and you see what melody kisses
are on facebook and as the name suggests
uh they melt pretty [ __ ] fast yeah so
i i really like it
it's hmm i like them it is just
basically mochi we have chocolate
and it's just basically actually you
know what that's really good
yeah i don't know what melty kiss you
had i think i had an awful like tasting
one this is just chocolate this is
[ __ ] good this is chocolate chip this
is really rich
it's just chocolate truffle right
there's no mochi in this is that
yeah think so there might be a mochi
variant oh i thought it was mochi so i
tasted that i didn't taste any more it's
like a truffle that's just yeah that's
just chocolate
i think i think that's just the truffle
and thank god they're all individually
wrapped so we can enjoy those later yeah
um i also have this is my channel that's
the monster
what is this oh my god i can't read
[ __ ] the phone come on
hunger jose you can do it
bro it's the fancy fonts [ __ ] me up in
japanese
oh that's code oh okay that looks like
that looks like a u doesn't it
i thought that was a huge i thought it
was a youtuber you
that's cute so it's separated into cute
little packages oh cute
so that's like perfect for dates yeah
yeah man you and your gf
rocking up okay how do you feel about
mochi um mid-tier
it depends it depends on the time like
mochi ice cream and like regular mochi
and like sweet small cheese is like
completely different in my opinion so
what is what is mochi again
mochi is just rice it's rice pudding
yeah so mochi is just rice
so basically they grab mochi rice which
is a specific type of rice
and they just [ __ ] mash it with a
hammer until it turns into
mochi that's good it's very chewy it's
just good shape
yeah that's clean
how i always feel about mochi is that
it's just very inoffensive
i would never not eat mochi but i would
never go out my way to get it but you
know like a lot
of old people die from choking on mochi
i can see why
yeah so when you eat mochi make sure
you're like yeah make sure you like
properly chew this [ __ ] otherwise it
will get stuck in your throat
i'm sorry i was laughing because i saw
one of gaunt's item i keep forgetting
it's called this it's called the
chocolate
pound cake for some reason that feels so
that is such a sexual energy that is
like a i never thought about that i was
like yeah
pound cake of course but when you say it
in english which is really weird that's
the chocolate pound cake yeah
you want to get some chocolate pound
cake that feels yeah see that that has
like that i've never had a food item
that has
raw sexual energy but that has it i mean
y'all want a chocolate pound cake what
the pound cake dude
honestly i mean it's just cake i don't i
don't use a fat block of chocolate yeah
i'll [ __ ] with you yeah that's good
i know i know what this tastes like yeah
i don't just taste it you're gone when
god has run out of energy he'll run into
the 7-eleven or
like family mart just buy one of these
yeah i don't know how you do that
so sometimes i just need a sugar rush uh
i don't i don't know
it's just a brownie yeah it literally
just tastes like a brownie yeah
i mean i mean like it's just a brownie
you don't i don't need to do it but it's
way more sexually sounding than a
broccoli a pound cake
pound cake does sound better than
brownie yeah just hold up the camera
that's nice right yeah yeah that's not
bad that's sexy
all right i think we are almost done
what do you have
i've got these like chocolates choco pie
oh god no yeah that just looks like a
panda chocolate
yeah but like not as good
france is crying right now i don't
really [ __ ] with these to be honest
yeah i'm gonna be honest i don't need to
try that yeah
yeah let's not open let's let's let's
open the stuff that is like only
what is that like that the [ __ ] is that
kid this is a
melon kitkat you're kidding me wow
because they have a kitkat they have
yeah like uh like that's a hokkaido
melon kit katsu that's the good melon
see the thing about like hokkaido melons
is that it is
expensive as [ __ ] here because
apparently it's
super amazing let's uh what kind a
melons
for preference is like one of like maybe
about that big
but a regular thing will cost you like
two three hundred dollars it's like
it's like the top class of melon
oh this is the bowl variety that we
tried yeah is this just going to taste
like kitkat again
whoa i [ __ ] with that i love melon
flavored [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's good yeah that is really
good oh my
god that might be one of the best ones
off yeah
hey give me some of that that's probably
the best kit kat i've ever had in my
life
that is such a clean flavor to it like
that straight up tastes like you're
eating a melon yeah
wow that's crazy it's it's like the
crunchiness of a biscuit and a kitkat
but with the clean taste of them of a
fruit wow i can't
that's really good wow you know how you
buy
a melon and it's god damn you know how
you bite into a melon and it just like
it feels like clean because it feels
like you're eating like a really watery
fruit yeah yeah for some reason that was
a completely dry snack that we just had
but it felt watery